[APPLAUSE]
GREG: HERE WAS GEORGE HERBERT
WALKER BUSH WHEN HE JUST TURNED
20.
AFTER RISKING HIS LIFE FOR HIS
COUNTRY ON NUMEROUS BOMBER
MISSIONS, HE WAS SHOT DOWN AND
RESCUED AT 20.
WHAT WAS I DOING AT 20?
GREG: I’M NOT WHAT YOU CALL A
POSTER BOY FOR HEROISM I HAVE
FLAT FEET WOULD GIVE YOU UP FOR
A SLICE OF POUNDCAKE.
IT’S EASY TO DRAW COMPARISONS
BETWEEN THEN AND NOW, 60 MILLION
AMERICANS FOUGHT IN WORLD WAR II
BUT TODAY 60 MILLION PEOPLE
WATCH THIS.
>> THAT IS REPAIRED BY GIVING
YOU SO MUCH OF MY TIME AND
ENERGY.
NO, I’VE GIVEN YOU EVERYTHING,
LISA.
GREG: YEAH, LISA.
YEAH.
THAT’S NO DIG AT NOW BUT JUST TO
POINT OUT A CONNECTION BETWEEN
TWO ERRORS.
ALL OF OUR ENTERTAINMENT AND
LEISURE TIME WAS ENABLED BY THE
BRAVERY OF PEOPLE YOU MIGHT
NEVER HAVE MET.
IF YOU HAVE ONE OF THE
16 MILLION IN YOUR CLAIM, I
SALUTE YOU.
YOU ARE LUCKY.
THEY MADE MY IDIOCY POSSIBLE.
TO QUOTE JOHN KERRY IN A TWEET
HE SENT TO ME --
FOR ONCE, THE
DRIFTWOOD DRACULA WAS RIGHT.
THE ONLY REASON WHY I CAN BE A
FULL TODAY IS BECAUSE SOMEONE
WAS A HERO YESTERDAY.
THANK YOU, JOHN, TO QUOTE ONE OF
YOUR SPECIAL FRIENDS --
YOUR SPECIAL FRIENDS -- ♫
♫.
GREG: WHEN HE HAD HAIR.
LOOKING BACK BUT THE PRICE OF
NOSTALGIA IS FOR GETTING A
PRESENT.
RATE MEN AND WOMEN TODAY DO OUT
THEY WERE PROTECTING YOU AND ME.
OUR MILITARY, LAW-ENFORCEMENT,
BORDER POLICE PATROL SO DO NOT
MISTAKENLY BELIEVE THIS IS A
GENERATION OF VIDEO GAMING SOFA
SERVERS.
MANY WOMEN DIE EVERY DAY FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
ALTHOUGH AT TIMES IT’S HARD TO
REMIND YOURSELF THAT THE REST OF
US AREN’T ALL IDIOTS, CHECK OUT
THIS TWEET FROM SLATE ABOUT
BUSH’S SERVICE DOG.
IMAGINE BEING THAT RIGHT OR
WHETHER PUSHES DOG DESERVES ALL
THE ATTENTION.
TODAY I WILL PUT THAT MUCH IN
ITS PLACE.
SKEWS ME, LIFELONG COMPANION.
SULLY IS NOT 94 YEARS OLD.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS LATE.
SORRY, SLATE.
SULLY CAN’T STEAL YOUR HOTPLATE
BECAUSE HE DOESN’T READ SLATE.
HE’S A DOG.
A SMART DOG.
FOR ONE MORE DAY YOU ARE A
SILLY, SILLY RAT.
OTHERS IN THE MEDIA KEPT AN
EAGLE.
MY GOD, WHAT WAS UP WITH HIS
JACKET?
>> HE WALKS INTO THE NATURAL
CATHEDRAL AND THE OTHER
PRESIDENTS ARE SEATED, HE IS
WEARING HIS OVERCOAT.
HE TAKES IT OFF AND HANDS SAID
CRUMPLED OVERCOAT TO THE YOUNG
MARINE OFFICER WHO WAS ACTING AS
HIS ESCORT.
WHAT IS GOING ON THERE?
WHY DID HE NOT JUST LEAVE THE
COAT IN THE BACK OF THE SEAT?
GREG: I HANDED TO BRIAN,
FOCUSING ON THE BIG PICTURE.
WHEN HE ISN’T BUSY MAKING UP
CRAP.
’S PRICE HE DID NOT SAY HE WAS
THERE BY LOOKING AT THE FOOTAGE.
YOU CAN’T SEE ME BUT A
)-RIGHT-PARENTHESIS TRUCK.
THEY’RE SO OBSESSED WITH TRUMP
THAT HE MISSED THE COOLEST
THING.
CHECK THIS BEER DOUBT.
SEE THE SPIRIT COMING?
IMAGINE WHAT YOU COULD HIDE IN
THAT BEARD.
I COULD HIDE IN THAT BEARD.
I COULD HIDE IN THERE FOR A
WEEK.
MEANWHILE, OTHERS USE THE
FUNERAL AS ANOTHER EXCUSE TO
TRASH THE PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT’S REALLY GOING ON RIGHT
NOW IS A NATIONAL REACTION TO
TRUMP.
MATTER WHAT WE SAY OR DON’T SAY
IT’S A REACTION TO WHAT WE HAVE
AND HONOR.
AND WE MISS THAT PART OF DECENCY
GREG: THANK YOU, CHRIS.
HE’S MORE OFF-BASE THAN A DRUNK
SHORTSTOP.
HERE’S WASHINGTON POST
HEADLINE -- OBVIOUSLY, THAT’S A
LIE.
EVEN I CAN’T STAND AND SIT AT
THE SAME TIME.
EVEN IN A TIME OF REVERENCE IN
UNITY THEY MISS THE POINT.
IF ONLY TOM’S HEAD WOULD SPROUT
HORNS, SPIN AROUND AND SPEW
FIRE.
IT TRUMP DID NOT GO, HE GETS
LAMP AND HE DOES GO, HE GETS
SLAMMED.
WHAT IS IRONIC ABOUT ALL OF THIS
IS WHAT DID THE FUNERALS ELEVATE
MOST?
WHEN HE THOUGHT OF MR. BUSH WHAT
DID YOU THINK MOST ABOUT?
PATRIOTISM, DUTY, FAMILY, FAITH.
ISN’T THAT THE STUFF THAT’S
OPENLY MOCKED TODAY BY
POP-CULTURE AND THE MEDIA,
ACADEMIA?
FOR PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THE EARTH
IS FLAT THAN BELIEVING IN
ANYTHING AND YET THIS WEEK THOSE
WERE THE THINGS THAT MATTERED.
WEIRD ISN’T IT?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT DEATH NOT
THINKING ABOUT IDENTITY OR
JACKETS FOR THE RESUME OF A
SERVICE BUT BUT I HOPE YOU LEARN
SOMETHING.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
PRESIDENT GEORGE HERBERT WALKER
BUSH FOUGHT IN WORLD WAR II,
FLEW 58 COMBAT MISSIONS, SHUT
DOWN, RESCUED THEN HE TURNED 21.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
LATER HE RAN THE CIA, HELPED AND
THE COLD WAR AND RESCUED KUWAIT
FROM IRAQ.
YET IN 1992 HE STILL LOST TO
BILL CLINTON.
JUST AS BOB DOLE DID FOUR YEARS
LATER.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT’S AMAZING LIFE PUT
HIM AT A CERTAIN AGE.
NO MORE HEROES PLEASE, WE’LL
TAKE THE YOUNG PHILANDERER.
WE HAVE THOUGHT IT OVER AND
DECIDED THE SAME PEOPLE WHO MAKE
SHALLOW DECISIONS ABOUT YOU MADE
ONE ABOUT HIM.
YOU JUST HAVE TO LAUGH.
THAT’S THE OTHER BIG MESSAGE
HERE.
BUSH WAS FUNNY.
HERE IS TRUTH.
>> LAST PAYMENT I WILL HAVE ON
BROCCOLI.
THERE ARE TRUCKLOADS OF BROCCOLI
AT THIS VERY MINUTE DESCENDING
ON WASHINGTON.
MY FAMILY IS DIVIDED.
I DO NOT LIKE BROCCOLI AND I’M
NOT LOCKED IT LIKED IT SINCE I
WAS A LITTLE KID AND MY MOTHER
MADE ME EAT IT AND I’M PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND ARE NOT
GOING TO EAT ANYMORE BROCCOLI.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
BANISHING HEROISM DON’T FORGET
BANISHING HUMOR.
HUMOR IS WHAT HOLDS THE
OPERATION, CIVILIZATION,
TOGETHER.
THE ONLY WAY TO CELEBRATE HATE
IS TO SHAME SENSOR HUMOR FROM
THE WORLD.
JOKES CONNECT PEOPLE ELIMINATE
THEM AND WE WON’T FALLING ON THE
FLOOR LAUGHING BUT FALLING ON
THE FLOOR.
IT’S WHY THE REAL HEROES DON’T
FIGHT COMMUNISM AND HITLER BUT
PEOPLE WHO CAN TAKE A DAMN JOKE.
HUMORLESS CREEPS SEEM TO BE
EVERYWHERE AND REPRODUCING.
AS WE GAIN THAT KIND OF NOXIOUS
NON- HERO WE LOSE MEN LIKE BUSH.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERAN AFFAIRS ROUGHLY 496,777
AMERICAN VETERANS WERE ESTIMATED
TO STILL BE ALIVE AT THE
SEPTEMBER 2018.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
THEY ARE STILL HERE.
HALF A MILLION OF THEM.
THEY’RE NOT MAKING MORE AND WE
SHOULD MAKE IT A POINT TO TALK
WITH THEM, LEARN FROM THEM AND
SHARE A LAUGH WITH THEM BECAUSE
THIS WEEK WE LOST AT LEAST ONE
AND IF WE LOSE MORE, AND THAT
FRIENDS, IS NO JOKE.
[APPLAUSE]
LET’S WELCOME TONIGHT’S GUESTS.
HE’S MORE COUNTRY THAN A MUDFLAP
MADE OF DAISY DUKES FROM THE DUO
BIG AND RICH, JOHN RICH.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
IF JOKES WERE SMOKING BE THE
MARBLE MAN.
JIMMY.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
NICE JACKET.
THE HOSTESS WITH THE MOST IS,
CAPTAINS TWO HE’S RESPONSIBLE
FOR MOST SOLAR ECLIPSES, FORMER
WWE SUPERSTAR AND MIGHT MASSIVE
SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: THANK YOU.
I LOVE HOW YOU ARE JUST A DAY.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS, GREG THE
FIVE NOT TALKING ABOUT YOU BUT
THE EXTRA FROM NEW KIDS ON THE
BLOCK.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS.
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO MY 86 -YEAR-OLD GRANNY RICH
WHO WATCHES YOUR SHOW.
SHE SMOKES A PACK OF MARLBORO
REDS EVERYDAY AND DRINKS WHISKEY
EVERY NIGHT AND STILL PULLED A
40 HOUR WEEK AND MADE THIS
JACKET AND JEANS.
GREG: WOW.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS IF I A
PACK OF CIGARETTES AND DRINK
BOOZE I CAN BECOME AN EXCELLENT
SEAMSTRESS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT IS POSSIBLE.
I WROTE A SONG ABOUT MY
GRANDFATHER WAS A WORLD WAR II
VET IN THE PACIFIC AND A TUNNEL
RAT SO HE’S A LITTLE GUY, 115
AND JOINED AT 17 AND LIED ABOUT
HIS AGE TO GET FIGHT AND WE
HEARD THE STORIES AND AT SIX
PURPLE HEARTS AND WENT OVER TO
THE PACIFIC AND THOUGHT I WROTE
A SONG CALLED THE GOOD LORD.
ON GEORGE BUSH 85th BIRTHDAY I
SANG THAT SONG BUT MISSED HIM
BECAUSE HE WAS JUMPING OUT OF AN
AIRPLANE AND THEN CALL ME BACK
AND SAID I WAS ON STAGE PLAYING
A BIG AND RICH CONCERT AND LET
ME THIS INCREDIBLE VOICEMAIL
THANKING ME FOR THE SONG AND I’M
SO GLAD I MISSED THE CALL
BECAUSE NOW I HAVE THE MESSAGE.
GREG: THAT’S TRUE BUT YOU PLAYED
IT FOR ME.
OR IT IS DANA GARVEY.
>> BUT THE BAD LITERALLY SAVE
THE WORLD AND WE KNOW THERE’S
HALF A MILLION LEFT AND IF YOU
GET A CHANCE TO SEE ONE OF THOSE
MEN SHAKE THEIR HAND AND GIVE
THEM A HUG AND SAY THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU DID FOR OUR COUNTRY.
HITLER WAS COMING AFTER US AND
BOMBED PEARL HARBOR AND COMING
FROM BOTH SIDES AMERICA STOOD UP
FROM BOTH SIDES AMERICA STOOD
UP, SHOWED ITS MIGHT AND RAN
THEM OFF.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
GREG: AND JIMMY, TALKING ABOUT
THE GREATEST GENERATION HOW DO
YOU FEEL ABOUT YOURSELF RIGHT
NOW?
>> I THOUGHT THIS LOOK GOOD WHEN
I WALKED FEELING LIKE A MILLION
I WALKED OUT OF THE HOUSE TODAY.
BUCKS AND THEN I CAUGHT A
LONGSHOT BEER ON THE SUBWAY AND
I LOOK LIKE A STRIPPER WHO LET
HIM GO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I CALL THIS THE TRAGIC MIKE
LOOK.
BUT TO YOUR POINT AND SCARED
ABOUT US LOSING THE GREATEST
GENERATION BECAUSE COUNTRY IS
GOING IN A SCARY DIRECTION.
WE ARE INCENTIVIZING THESE KIDS
TO BE WHIPS.
IN NEW YORK, WE MAKE FUN OF WHAT
WE WOULD CALL SOUTHERN REDNECKS
BECAUSE OF A STEREOTYPICAL THING
TO DO BUT I THANK GOD FOR THAT.
THEY’RE THE ONLY ONES RAISING
TOUGH KIDS.
ARE YOU WITH ME?
IF ISIS SHOWS UP TOMORROW YOU’RE
NOT CALLING HUGS, HOPPER IN
VAIN.
YOU’RE CALLING BOBBY JOE, BUBBA
AND CLETUS.
THEY WILL TAKE ISIS OUT USING
RIFLES THEY GOT FOR THEIR TENTH
BIRTHDAY.
I’M WITH MR. RICH.
GREG: ALL RIGHT, CAT?
KAT: I LOVE THAT PHOTO OF THE
SERVICE DOG LAYING IN FRONT OF
THE CASKET.
HOW DARE ANYONE MAKE FUN OF THAT
HOW DARE ANYONE MAKE FUN OF
THAT.
GREG: WHAT WAS THIS PERSON
THINKING.
KAT: DOGS ARE SO GREAT.
IF I EVER DIE WHICH I MAY --
>> I DON’T KNOW.
KAT: MY KAT WOULD WALK UP AND
LAY DOWN NEXT TO ME BUT IT WOULD
BE TO EAT MY FACE.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THAT’S ACAT.
IT’S ALMOST LIKE YOUR SECOND
PRICING YOURSELF.
YEAH, I SUPPOSE WHICH MAKES ME
ALMOST A MILITARY HERO.
I’M JUST KIDDING.
I’M NOT.
I’M GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE
VETERANS BECAUSE PERSONALLY
BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF ANXIETY I
GET FROM JANKE I CANNOT GO TO
WAR.
GREG: I’M BAR THEM FROM COMBAT
AS CAN BE.
TYRUS, THOUGHTS?
TYRUS: I THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT
WEEK TO REMEMBER WHAT’S
IMPORTANT IN THIS COUNTRY.
I THOUGHT GEORGE BUSH JUNIOR
SPEECH OF HIS FATHER WAS
POWERFUL AND AMAZING AND I DON’T
HAVE A DAD BUT IF I DID I WOULD
HOPEFULLY TALK ABOUT HIM LIKE
THAT.
WOW, DADS DO ALL THAT.
WOW.
IT WAS COOL.
AT THE SAME TIME I DID A LOT OF
LAUGHING.
THE PRESIDENT, IF HE DOESN’T GO
TO THE FUNERAL, HE’S THE WORST
MAN ON THE PLANET.
HE GOES TO THE FUNERAL, REACHES
OVER AND SHAKES THE HAND OF AN
ADVERSARY, CLASSY MOVE, OBAMA
SHOOK HIS HAND BACK AND STILL
WAS THE WORST MAN IN THE WORLD.
WE CAN’T WIN WITH YOU.
THAT WAS THE STORY, NOT THE
AMAZING BUREAU IN TIME TO FORGET
ABOUT DIVISION AND POLITICS BUT
STILL WERE LIKE NO WE NEED A
TRUMP STORY.
HE DID NOT SHAKE HANDS WITH
OBAMA.
LET’S DO IT.
RUN IT.
THAT’S WHERE RAT AND IT’S
SIMPLE.
GREG: WE HAVE TO MOVE ON BUT
ABOUT PLANNING YOUR OWN FUNERAL
IS A LOT OF PRESSURE AND GEORGE
BUSH WROTE HALF OF HIS OWN PLAN.
I HAVE ONE PAGE I CAME UP WITH
IT.
DON’T DROP THE ASHES.
DON’T INVITE ANYONE FROM MAROON
FIVE.
OPEN BAR BUT NO FANCY DRINKS
BECAUSE I DON’T LIKE LINES.